okay hier ist abgelegt nein ich hab's
nicht abgedeckt ist voll so geklungen
durst abgelegt nein habe ich nicht
aber ja ich wähle ich hab's ja etwas
gedacht und willkommen beim ein video ja
leute heute ist wieder was cooles
angesagt jetzt irgendwie voll angst dass
man hier beobachtet wird und zwar gibt
es ja in köln viele läden wir sind am
liebsten kfc und wir machen heute für
den ultimativen test blind erschreckend
cathy us is fei deswegen was noch dazu
ergänzen
nur casey man will ja gegen phelps
welches verkauft sie ja das ist halt ein
paar anfängt caves die was so tut so da
gibt es dieses einig weil ich will jetzt
nicht den namen dann nachher kriegen
wieder irgendwie schick rechtliche
probleme auf jeden fall haben die genau
die gleichen sachen so ungefähr und wir
holen das dann erschrecken das blind und
vielleicht ist ja das fag dingen sogar
besser wer weiß aber wir müssen erst mal
auftanken sonst bleiben wir liegen sechs
stunden später so leute wir haben jetzt
vielleicht 1 gekauft also wir sind echte
vollbepackten des unterwäsche
aber ich würde sagen wir sind sofort
wieder und dann wird getestet
ging es da ging es da ja wenn so leute
jetzt mir einmal kfc natürlich verdeck
mal den namen haben wir den fake sie was
ich aber schon mal von vornherein sagen
kann
casey hat 21 euro kostet alles was
geholt habe und das feld dinge nur 13
eur 47 also einfach mal schneller
günstiger das spricht er schon mal dafür
wir gucken jetzt so wie es schmeckt und
jaletzke sollte was geht alter ja ich
hab euch geht's gut an wir haben jetzt
hier schon ordentlich fleißig einkaufen
vergab schon gesagt haben wir sie hier
haben wir das
andere rapids geholt das steht ja hier
drauf auf jeden fall einmal diese hot
wings dann diesen viele bürger dann auch
die viel leben und dann auch irgendwie
diese normalen gehörten die ist sogar
ziemlich warm
wir wollen nämlich verarschen haben
jetzt den burger dann vergessen was oder
hast du den stil ausreichend ich habe da
gar nicht gibt darauf erhält die können
doch jetzt sich einfach den burger junge
was könnt ihr alltag vor allem der
bürger ziehen euro gekostet wenn die
zwei krone spaß
jetzt können wir schon eine sache
knicken die ich unbedingt testen wollte
so dass hier ist eindeutig besser kauft
hier ein
das war's mit dem video ja gut ist dann
halt so
aber ich weiß ja ungefähr wie das merkt
auch bin okay und ich dachte jetzt egal
was gleich hierher genau was ich auch
noch etwas was schon bitte mit behaupten
ja ok nein jung ich sie gar nichts so
leute ich habe ja noch gar nicht das
prinzip wird also ich versuche jetzt
vielleicht ja schon gesagt casey ist
eingeladen sind wir öfter mal und
ich bin jetzt schon gespannt ob ich das
auch rückkehr schmecke oder ob man hier
auch mal so was helfen kann weil es ja
deutlich günstiger anscheinend und man
kennt es nicht mehr
ok also wie sies nächsten nähe jetzt
habe ich den wind zu gespürt wie du
schlägst mich jetzt fragen wir den
anschluss und macht bitte auch mal dran
aber so naja oder gib mir das denn die
haben keine ahnung und ich bin im
university ein bisschen rasche nämlich
du nicht raus kommen vielleicht fangen
heute ein kommissar gibt's hier noch
einfach in die hand kein okay
fangen wir mit dem ersten teil an 30 30
machen wir ein bisschen dran ist ein
knochen drin hier oben ist was hast du
damit gemacht nichts hast du darauf
geeinigt hatte nichts damit immer noch
[Musik]
schön oder
wahrscheinlich wird von cape stegers
einheit verfügt ist sie sicher wenn man
sich erst mal das andere wären wir da
nicht so sicher
das war vor lag mit sicherheit jetzt
wissen wir dass andere mache auch nichts
dran bitte jetzt halten
das schmeckt aber ziemlich trocken war
das ist gar nicht mal das ist dem
anderen immer einfach ganz zu 100% kfc
zu 1000 2000 war das nicht das werk
absolut nicht dass wir wirklich mal
probiert
ich muss jetzt noch schmeckt total
ausgetrocknet jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
die kommentare die post bei pepsi finde
ich sogar eigentlich immer ganz lecker
ja das dii ist die sind unterschiedlich
dick egal
fangen wir an mit der ersten promis so
lippmann noch eine das fun ist aber zwei
unterschiedliche oder warte gibt immer
noch einen grippe noch mal die mehr als
jetzt aufnehmen was machen mit dieser
weise
ich hab schon gedacht
weißt du schon
ich würde sagen die wir noch mal kurz
die zweite frage erfahren junge falsch
ich würde aber sagen die letzten matches
crash tief die zweite dass er schmeckt
erlebten oder was ist halt so ich würde
sagen dass wir das projekt erstes
gegeben hat das war die feld und das was
du mir als zweites gegeben hast das war
casey nur die fake schmeckt besser die
schmeckt irgendwie so mehr nach leckeren
pommes anstatt einfach nach dem
ausgetrockneten stück stoff so bis sie
sich hier die erste wahl von die erste
davon fällt aber die ist besser für mich
durch auflösen die hat war ich ja ich
bin so gut machen wir das nächste news
echt gut
ich finde es immer noch so eine
frechheit dass sie einfach den bürger
nicht rein getan haben also was hast
dich ja dumm wenn ich das nicht meine
finger kriege gibt es erst mal ärger
achtung das jetzt mit
mit knochen dann nehmen wir das mal in
die hand zum bogen es gibt ja abschaffen
gekauft oder aber bei beiden das ist auf
jeden fall schwer zu sagen es hat okay
geschmeckt aber es war jetzt nicht
bezaubernd gewitter das am trifft das
nächste oder soll ich schon mal sagen
wovon ich vermute ist es nenne jetzt mal
das zweite
dies ist zweiter hand auf hand und das
ist auf jeden fall schwer aber ich bin
immer wieder eigentlich fast zu 100
prozent sicher weil das hier schmeckt
eindeutig besser das hier ist chelsea da
ist dann immer so von von der konsistenz
ist das irgendwie ein bisschen anders
das ist kfc und das andere war das feld
sicher ganz sicher nicht einfach der
wind erschwerte gibt einmal kurz zum
bürger weil man muss sagen wenn man
nichts sieht das auge ist der mittel
dann kann man das anders schmecken
ich will mal kurz probiert ob der lecker
ist eine tomate darauf weil er wegen bin
ich allergisch ist eine dort war der
gehalt weiter hat der ist echt lecker
aber der war schon vor dem feld
ich muss sagen das gefällt mir echt gute
zieht aber auch ein zweiter aus wie
vielen aspekten so und das nächste muss
jetzt rausfinden von wo es ist keine
zwei auswahlmöglichkeiten muss
herausfinden von welcher marke das ist
habe ich das schon warum wertvoll alter
was das dann ist nur diesen stück das
was ist das hier unten
das ist einfach bei dem stück draht bis
zum rattenschwanz nein
ist das jüngste setzen jetzt ist
gastgeschenke kirsch
was hast du noch irgendwas jetzt was ich
noch nicht hier probiert haben ja dann
gebt mir das jetzt mal bitte wirklich
bin ich schön ist das ja das gleiche
aber erst richtig gemacht applaus für
alex haupt den bau jetzt bin ich morgens
ab juli auch in der regel aber gib mir
keinen müll ich habe ja auch keinen
einstieg ein will jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob wir genauso gut bist wie ich
möchte daran hab ein bisschen das ist
ein chicken wing glaube ja das müsste
wird klar sein müsse dass die gemachte
nichts und sagte dass es technisch casey
sicher 100pro dass das andere her gehen
wir mal das gegenstück wenn sie wieder
mit depp folgt volg laden
das ist casey das ist fähig 100 ja ich
gehe jetzt als nächstes mal die form ist
voll das komische gefühl so blöd zu sein
okay hier ist die erste panne deswegen
was damit geworden ist jetzt wird mir
noch eine von dem was willst du sagen so
die dakar ist voll okay dann gebe ich
dir ist eine andere
hier verspricht dass die gleiche passt
dass die gleiche logik dass genau die
gleiche ja okay dann gebe ich dir jetzt
eine andere ja dass eine andere und was
da was ist davon etwas das leipziger
safety assist
so einfach aber was wird zu sagen das
besser der fake der fake verdi sind sehe
ich auch gesagt dass er da bricht ja ja
ist richtig halte um die ecke wieso
leute kommen zur letzten sache oder
ich bin okay hier das abgedeckt nein ich
habe es nicht abgedeckt ist voll so
geklungen
nein habe ich nicht für alle ja ich
wähle ich hab's ja ich traue mich oben
nicht zuerst nur ich denke das gemacht
was sagst es lecker geht folgt
also schon dass eine von den beiden
wirklich liebe täglich was ist casey
sicher 100 proben ja wichtig ich hab
nicht gefeiert fifa jetzt mich gar nicht
hätte aber genau das macht uns wieder ab
hier ja heute also zum abschluss kann
man sagen sie ist eindeutig besser und
man schmeckt es auch sofort zumindest
wenn man vorher schon mal gegessen habt
schreibt man die kommentare was ihr
davon am liebsten es möchte er die hot
wings oder die crispy filets oder wie
auch immer die heißen schreibt sie die
kommentare last auf jeden fall ein
viertel nach oben da genau wie das dann
morgen wieder schaut euch auch auf jeden
fall das video beim julia ich verdient
ganz oben der video beschreibung ist
zusammengetreten
haut rein bis morgen
[Musik]